amy hey how's it going uh it's going
all right how are you uh you know
hanging in uh so how's the history magazine
these days it's bloody jacob very bloody
okay tell me not too much more but a little bit
more vampires jacob we're working on a story about
vampires and the origins of the dracula story
that sounds spooky okay uh what have you found
okay so you know count dracula right yeah it's
bram stoker's novel and we're looking into the you
know the source material for it so it turns out
count dracula is based in part on an actual guy
he's known as vlad tepas or as his enemies called
him vlad the impaler ooh okay so he rolled back
in the 1400s in what is now romania and so he
dies and his detractors write about how brutal
the guy was and you know they're not really
lying like vlad was pretty brutal like he was a
ruthless enemy he actually did impale a bunch of
people on big pointy spikes to kill them i mean
not not somebody wanted to tangle with yeah
so years later bram stoker he's researching
a new novel he's writing about a vampire and
so he's he goes to he goes to romania and he's
doing some research and comes across this name
dracula which is a fabulous name for a vampire
it means son of the dragon and so he bases
his count dracula character in part on vlad
so aside from a few details you know stoker
makes up the rest you know vlad isn't nocturnal
vlad wasn't sucking people's blood he wasn't a
vampire and he definitely did not turn into a bat
do we know if he liked garlic i think the
jury is out on garlic i think they were too
busy writing about the impaling to worry
about the culinary thing but i'll look into it
well i'll tell you amy what i've learned is
that that bat part has really stuck um i've been
working on a story about bats and i gotta tell you
they have a lot of baggage i mean for hundreds of
years people have seen bats as bloodsuckers and
disease carriers just generally bad luck i mean
well i mean aren't they well here's the thing
i met this scientist named rodrigo medellin and
he's really helped me understand why bats are our
friends and they help make a lot of good things
possible things that are in our life every single
day and they also occupy this kind of magical
and mysterious place in our minds um and it's
that world that you know rodrigo really wants
to bring us into yeah but aren't there vampires
there no vampires all right it's well i'm gonna
make it worth your while i promise okay as long as
it's safe i'm ready to go with you all right cool
so it's probably not a surprise that a bat
researcher spends a lot of time in caves
but what is a surprise at least to me is how
much those caves reinvigorate rodrigo medellin
that's the most amazing feeling on earth i
always use the opportunity to be in a cave
to reconnect with myself they're like his
own private portal to some other world
when rodrigo goes into these
caves he's often with other people
like students but he finds ways to have the
cave all to himself once we're done with the
work etc i send everyone out of the cave and i
remain behind just enjoying just soaking in the
peace the silence the tranquility in an absolute
dark environment now i myself don't go into caves
i think they're pretty scary but rodrigo says when
you turn off your flashlight the darkness in there
is so profound it becomes beautiful in its own
way it's like you're shrouded in in felt in like a
beautiful silky feeling that just hugs you
and welcomes you to an amazing place in which
you usually as a human being you're
not considering as welcoming for you
in fact with nothing to see your body
puts your other senses on high alert
your nose picks up the smell of bats especially
their guano and your ears are busy too
there's the flight of the bats flying around you
occasionally but there's also uh the squealing of
the bats themselves when they are in their
in their niches in in the on the walls etc
i mean with all that going on it must be hard
to hear yourself think well the first time that
i take students into a cave yes they there's so
many emotions and so many questions that they have
that it's very very difficult to really you know
assume a pose of tranquility and peace but once
you've done it for decades oh my god i'm looking
forward to the next time i'm gonna be in a cave
rodrigo is on a quest to make people see bats the
same way he does with a sense of wonder and awe i
mean think about it they're the only mammal that
can fly which is pretty incredible and there are
more than 1400 different bat species which makes
them one of the most diverse types of mammals but
the deck is stacked against them hundreds
of years of myth-making has painted batz's
spooky blood-sucking disease-carrying villains
there's many animals that have a negative public
image from snakes to spiders to scorpions to
sharks to bats none of those animals do more for
your everyday life quality than bats today many
species of bats are at the brink of extinction
and a world without bats could have major ripple
effects for the clothes you're wearing right now
for the food on your table and even for the
cocktail you sip at the end of a long day
put it this way bats may not be the hero everyone
wants but right now they're the hero we need
i'm jacob penner and this is overheard a show
where we eavesdrop on the wild conversations we
have here at nat geo and follow them to the
edges of our big weird beautiful world this
week the man on a mission to change how we see
bats one product that relies on bats is tequila
we'll explain how rodrigo convinced skeptical
tequila producers to team up with them
and come on who wants to live in a world with
no tequila plus why covet 19 misinformation is
putting bats in danger and how rodrigo is
set in the record straight more after this
so i have to fess up that for the longest time
my knowledge of bats started and basically ended
with halloween i mean bats are spooky right and a
story i guess i assume that even studying bats was
kind of a creepy endeavor it turns out at least
according to rodrigo medellin i was totally wrong
i am a professor of ecology at the
national autonomous university of mexico
and i'm lucky enough to be one of the happiest
people i know today rodrigo is a national
geographic explorer at large he's been studying
bats and evangelizing for them for decades he's
even picked up the nickname the batman of mexico
which i guess is inevitable if you study bats long
enough but just like a comic book hero rodrigo's
journey started with a mythical origin story
i i started with an interest on animals from
a very very early age i mean my first word
was not mama or dada or doodoo
my first word was flamingo
flamingo flamingo yeah i mean i i said
my mom reflected it in my baby book
saying well little rodrigo said his first word
today he was looking at a pic at the book with
pictures of animals and he was pointing at
a flamingo and he said gangling or something
like that i mean i gotta say if if i was if if
my kid did that i would be very impressed don't
get me wrong i think i'd also be a little bit
hurt that they didn't want to say my name first
and you would the thought would also cross your
mind that there's something really weird with
your kids i mean sorry but it is true now little
rodrigo would just inhale books about wildlife
anything he could get his hands on but especially
mammals so one day when he's 11 years old he's
watching this mexican game show the 64 000 peso
grand prize rodrigo turns to his mom and says you
know if i could get on this show and they asked
me questions about mammals i think i could win
and my mom says no no you you go play you're
11 years old you're not supposed to be
know it all about mammals no no no go play
i insisted and insisted and insisted that
my mom finally took me to the producers now
to be clear this was a game show for adults
the producers completely dismissed
rodrigo they told him and his mom
look this isn't some kind of parlor
game and we're just not interested
so rodrigo's mom threw down the gauntlet and my
mom said well ask the kid a question if you think
that he doesn't know so they pulled a book and
they started asking questions about mammals
an eleven-year-old rodrigo nailed the pop quiz
and soon enough they said well congratulations
because you're going to be the first kid in
the show so how'd it go it went really well but
no i'm sorry to disappoint you i did not win the
64 000 peso price i was going for 32 000 pesos
and that is the question that i did not
answer but my god did i ever win a prize
now this was back in the days when there were
only like three tv channels and no netflix
so a ton of people were watching rodrigo including
the most influential mammal researcher in mexico
who was apparently pretty impressed he dialed
the tv station and asked for rodrigo's phone
number he called me home and he said listen
if you want to continue learning about mammals
why don't you come over to the university of
mexico the institute of biology and we will take
you to the field and we will show you mammals for
real so that you can continue learning about them
that's when rodrigo started using his superpowers
for good once he got hooked on bats he realized
they're victims of a big misunderstanding bats
have a lot of things going for them like the
fact that they fly and use echolocation or the
fact that there's so many different species
and then there are more practical benefits take
just one bat species as an example the mexican
free-tailed bat there are tens of millions of them
in mexico alone and even more in the u.s and they
love to eat insects each million of those bats
destroys 10 tons of insects every night so just
imagine what would happen if we lose those bats
overnight well in a few months we're not going
to have any crops because the insects are going to
be accumulating and accumulating and accumulating
they're going to eat up all of our crops rodrigo
says corn cotton coffee they all rely on bats to
keep insect numbers down plus bats also spread
seeds and pollinate some flowering plants
so a healthy bat population means fewer
insects and more fruit and flowers
sounds pretty good right well this is
where the misunderstanding comes in
rodrigo says you can trace our fear of bats back
to one moment a little more than 500 years ago it
was when the spanish conquistador air non-cortez
landed on the shores of what's now mexico
and one of his scribes gonzalo fernandez de obiedo
notices that the first night that they spent
on the coast of mexico he saw these flying little
animals that come out at night that land on the
horses or under on the soldiers and bite them
to feed on their blood these were vampire bats
they're native only to the americas
so the spaniards had never seen them
and they do feed on blood not human blood
except in extremely rare cases mostly cows
but rodrigo says that was enough for our minds
to start running and you know that blood is a
material that spikes our imagination you know an
animal that is feeding on on on that sacred liquid
is automatically enshrouded in in in a in a sea
of mystery and our imagination just takes off
and and then we start linking them with with
processes that are really not true at all even
though just three species of bats drink blood and
there are well over a thousand species that don't
cortez's account made a connection in western
culture between bats and blood sucking so that was
the first thing the second happened a few hundred
years later on the other side of the atlantic
ocean an irish lad named bram stoker was cooking
up the vampire story that we know as dracula
turns out that dracula bram stalker's vampire had
this problem that he needed to to travel very long
distances in a very uh very fast right so braun
stalker stumbles upon this vampire bat of the
new world and he immediately thinks oh i know
what my vampire will do he will turn into a bat
fly all of this distance then become another human
being again and then bite the girl for her blood
and then people run around saying i want to
suck your blood and you know and then it's stuck
and then the public image of bats came tumbling
down like crazy and it created a nightmare for
all of us bad biologists in the world we have been
united to combat to counter that negative image
that negative image has real world consequences
it encourages people to hurt bats and on a bigger
level it puts whole species of bats in danger the
good news is that rodrigo and other bat scientists
have ways of fighting back and what could i
tell you as a mexican about tequila you know
coming up how tequila helped rescue an endangered
bat species salute that's after the break
for about 12 million years mother nature
fine-tuned a process to grow agave the plant
that's fermented to make tequila agaves are a type
of succulent they have spiky leaves fanning out
kind of in a spiral each agave plant waits its
entire life for one single reproductive event
when a tall flower sprouts up out of the middle
of the plant now that flower is dinner for bats
especially one species called the lesser
long-nosed bat which love to eat agave nectar they
attract the the bats to come and and lick that
nectar and in the process be completely covered
with their pollen that they are going
to carry to the next the next agave
to the next agave and the next agave but that
process that took millions of years to perfect
humans threw it out of whack as people began
commercially farming agave for tequila production
they started to cut corners they didn't want to
wait years for agave plants to flower naturally
so they cloned agave plants this was
cheaper and easier but it came with a
cost one night in the 1990s rodrigo medellin
was hanging out with some other scientists
and we were sipping tequila what else right and
and then we started talking about how there was
a complete disconnect between the tequila
that we were shipping and the baths that are
responsible for that tequila in the 90s the lesser
long-nosed bat was on the endangered species list
and all of the agave cloning was considered
a factor because it takes away the bat's food
plus rodrigo thought the cloning was also bad
for the tequila industry natural reproduction
creates genetic diversity but with clones every
single plant shares the same dna one disease
that hits one plant and all of your plants are
going to be sick because they're all the same
they're exactly the same so all it takes is for
one disease to hit one plant and you'll be doomed
so rodrigo approached mexico's tequila regulatory
council he proposed a plan that he thought was a
pretty good one he wanted to allow more natural
agave reproduction he argued it would be good for
the bats and good for tequila so everybody wins
and i show them pictures etc and they said wow
that's a fantastic story thank you very much for
telling us and i suggested a number of messages
there and they said well thank you very much for
coming dr managing that was fascinating good bye
that was the end of it yeah he says they didn't
really want to hear it but rodrigo and some other
scientists were getting pretty concerned that
a catastrophic blight could wipe out agaves so
rodrigo went back to the tequila council and they
again said wow thank you very much for coming
fascinating stuff bye i hope they at least gave
you like a bottle of tequila for the road for
your trouble not even not even and then it
happened rodrigo says around 2010 and 2011
a disease slammed agave crops a double whammy of
fungus and bacteria and just like he had warned it
was the big one and i swear jacob it was not me i
didn't put it in there it wasn't me right but then
they reach out and they say oh my god what
was that idea about the bats and the flowers
and the pollen that you were saying i said well
you're late but let's see what we can do now that
he finally had the ear of some tequila producers
rodrigo explained his plan farmers would manage 95
of their crops exactly the same as before but
the last five percent would be set aside for
bats to pollinate naturally which gives the agaves
more genetic diversity and it gives the bats more
food and i explained to them what they needed to
do to allow five percent of the agaves to flower
and harvest the remaining 95 percent
and that will be their safety passage
for the next generations of agaves and they
immediately said wow that makes all the sense
in the world why didn't do we do this before so
correct me if i'm wrong but it sounds like your
sales pitch to the tequila producers is almost
like setting up a savings account like you
put this five percent aside this is agave
that you can't i guess make profit from now
but it keeps your long-term success looking
better exactly it's it's an insurance policy
in 2016 rodrigo created a pilot program that
certified brands that follow these rules
today those labels have little logos showing that
they're officially bat friendly tequila around
the same time rodrigo was starting the program
the bat world got great news partly because of
rodrigo's work in 2015 mexico removed the lesser
long-nosed bat from its endangered species list
it was the first mexican mammal ever to make
that kind of improvement so there were signs
that bat conservation was working but last
year rodrigo ran into his biggest challenge yet
the coronavirus now i want to be really clear
here when it comes to the origins of sars cov2
which is the virus that causes covet 19 there's
still a lot we just don't know you may remember
that from the beginning of the pandemic bats have
been blamed as a possible carrier of the virus
and scientists are still investigating
whether bats were the source of the virus
rodrigo says it is true that bats
naturally carry some coronaviruses
but there's many other groups of mammals and even
birds that have other coronaviruses so you cannot
say that bats gave us kovid so far nobody has
pinpointed the exact source of this coronavirus
and regardless you won't get kovid just
from coming into contact with a bat
with some misinformation claimed bats
could give people covet even though
it was wrong that blame game has had real and
devastating effects on bats all over the world
in indonesia the government killed hundreds
of bats supposedly for public safety in rwanda
government officials sprayed bat colonies
with a fire hose and rodrigo he followed
it all i don't think i have ever worked
harder than in the past year and a half
trying precisely to defuse the unfounded
accusations against baths and of course
when you see that people are killing bats because
of some scientists saying that bats gave us this
it's not fair jacob so as far as what you and
i can do rodrigo says it's pretty simple be a
bat defender you can go the extra mile
by putting up a bat house in your yard
or for starters just spread the word talk to your
neighbor talk to your friends talk to your family
talk to the office people about baths and about
what you've learned in this podcast rodrigo says
you can help out in your own area too find out
who's conserving bats in your neighborhood and
maybe even visit a bat cave you might just
surprise yourself and like it more than you think
it's such a natural development
it's such a natural process
to become at home at peace in a cave because
remember jacob that we as human beings only
10 thousand years ago only twenty fifty thousand a
hundred thousand years ago we were living in caves
so caves are our natural home and what i'm doing
is just going back home that's what i'm doing
if you're ready to learn more
about bats and be a bat defender
well we got you covered check out more of
rodrigo's work including a short documentary
that follows rodrigo as he looks for a rare
species of vampire bat inside an ancient mayan
ruin there's a link in our show notes and you
can also find more facts and figures about bats
i mean there's so much variety on one end of
the spectrum there's the kitty's hognose bat
weighs less than a penny and on the other
flying foxes have a six-foot wingspan
also we have a fun video breaking down how dracula
created some of those damaging myths about bats
and you can read more about why it's so
tricky to nail down the origins of cobit 19.
plus for subscribers journey into one of the
largest and wildest caves in the world in borneo
it has caverns so enormous that a
jetliner could fit comfortably inside
and it's home to millions of bats that's in
the show notes right there in your podcast app
now if you like what you hear and you
want to support more content like this
please rate us and review us in your podcast app
and consider a national geographic subscription
that's the best way to support overheard
go to natgeo.com explore to subscribe
overheard at national geographic is produced by
alanna strauss brian gutierrez marcy thompson
bianca martin and me jacob penner laura sam
also helped produce this one laura best of
luck in your next adventure our senior editor
is eli chen our senior producer is carla wills
our executive producer of audio is devar ardulon
our fact-checkers are robin palmer and julie beer
our copy editor is amy kolzack hansdale
sue composed our theme music and he sound
designed and engineered this episode the national
geographic society is committed to illuminating
and protecting the wonder of our world and funds
the work of national geographic explorer at large
rodrigo medellin this podcast is a production of
national geographic partners whitney johnson is
the director of visuals and immersive experiences
susan goldberg is national geographic's editorial
director and i'm jacob penner thanks
for listening we'll see you next time
you